[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'hebdo une
émission pour revenir sur l'actualité
départementale de la semaine voici les
titres de ce vendredi 5 mais ils sont
désormais armés les policiers municipaux
des l'umq ont reçu hier leur nouvel
équipement des mains du maire les douze
agents ont notamment suivi une formation
pour appréhender ces armes de poing
c'est une première pour l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines philippe
libérer notre invité fil rouge pour
cette émission secrétaire de la nouvelle
section des anciens combattants de
maurepas il nous dira pourquoi recréer
cette section disparu il y à plus de 70
euros lequel compte jouer notamment
auprès des plus jeunes
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
locale nous reviendrons sur la deuxième
édition du challenge robotique qui se
tenait jeudi 4 mai au prisme ou encore
la ville de trappes qui a organisé son
forum un job d'été et de l'apprentissage
c'était mercredi après vélizy à cap sur
bois d'arcy pour quart matt l'entreprise
à la base du coeur artificiel qui vient
tout juste d'être autorisé à reprendre
ses essais par l' agence nationale du
médicament a annoncé dans la foulée son
implantation sur un nouveau site d'ici
la fin de l'année sur la zone
d'activités de la croix bonnet à bois
d'arcy plus précisément 50 à 80
ingénieurs y seront présents une bonne
nouvelle forcément pour la ville et son
développement économique
écoutez le maire c'est vrai que c'est un
travail quotidien
un travail quotidien c'est un travail de
de dialogue de réseaux de d'essayer de
convaincre les entreprises de venir sur
un territoire
il faut qu'ils soient attirés par ce
territoire et c'est vrai que depuis un
certain temps la ville de bray rssi ati
on a eu paris-nice dernièrement on a eu
beaucoup de bonnes nouvelles qui fait
que qui font que les entreprises sont
attirées par bonnart si l'arrivée de la
fibre sur bonnart 6 cette année est
aussi un élément pour que les
entreprises arrivent 700 première à
saint quentin en yvelines et qui
marquent probablement un tournant dans
la politique sécuritaire des communes le
maire d'elancourt jean michel fourgous a
remis ce jeudi à 4 mai des armes aux
douze agents de la police municipale une
décision prise au lendemain des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015
nicolas d'andré c'est une étape franchie
par la police municipale d'elancourt
douze agents ont reçu une arme de poing
individuel un équipement complémentaire
au gilet pare-balles taser ou encore
flash ball pour ce brigadier ce sera un
pistolet beretta 9 mm pour nous on le
prend vraiment comme un outil de travail
on est conditionné pour travailler avec
une arme
après on sent on s'entraîne nous toutes
les semaines sur la commune d'el en
cours pour avec différents types
d'exercices avec amour les policiers
municipaux ont reçu 45 heures de
formation théorique et pratique sur le
maniement des armes
ils sont passés au crible de
l'administration pour obtenir leur
autorisation
objectif assurer une meilleure
protection de la population
c'est vrai que s'il y a une montée
brutale de tension ou un acte comme on a
vu sur les champs elysées ou ou dans
d'autres circonstances
il s'agit bien sûr qu'il puisse exercer
la légitime défense
compte tenu aussi bien sûr dans un
contexte qui s'est un petit peu dégradée
ils sont formés très sévèrement ils ont
ils un contrôle de moralité
c'est une expérience de maîtrise de
formation donc les et puis même
légalement ils savent dans quel cadre
ils peuvent ou ne peuvent ou ne peuvent
pas bien sûr sortir leurs armes c c'est
extrêmement cadré
d'autres projets sont en cours le
renforcement de la collaboration avec la
police nationale ou encore le
développement du futur commissariat
d'agglomération à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la commune de
villepreux pourrait aussi armée et sa
police municipale avant fin 2010 est et
pour être tout à fait précis sur le
sujet sachez que les 20 armes qui
équipent les agents municipaux
d'elancourt ont coûté près de 10 mille
dix mille et excusez-moi 10000 euros à
la commune on poursuit cette émission
avec notre invité fil rouge philippe
luber bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes membre
et secrétaire de la section mauricienne
des anciens combattants nouvelle section
puisque elle a été relancé au début du
mois d'avril
avant de parler de ce sujet sur sur
l'actualité convient aux convient de
voir l'armement des policiers municipaux
certains sont contre certains sont pour
vous vous avez eu à manier dans votre
vie des armes vous êtes aussi citoyen de
maurepas la ville juste à côté
d'elancourt qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est ce que c'est une bonne solution
selon vous
maniement d'armes faut toujours être
prudent d'accord il faut une formation
mais sinon vous êtes pour la plus
précise possible
on revient au sujet de votre venue la
renaissance de la section locale des
anciens combattants je parle de
renaissance parce qu'elle existait à
maurepas il y a très longtemps jusqu'à
la seconde guerre mondiale si je me
trompe pas pourquoi avait-elle disparu
peut-être un petit mode histoire sur ben
était criant la première fois en 1924 et
puis s'est effiloché au fil du temps
pour s'éteindre
pendant la guerre de 39 40 et ici il ya
une reprise maintenant avec de nouveaux
membres
et puis un terrain d'action expliquez
nous pourquoi vous avez décidé de
recréer cette section ça date de quand
cette idée de relance est passée par là
forum des associations où le nc était
présente et en discutant avec les
membres qui étaient là ça permet de
savoir quelle est l action de l'ue etc
étant donné qu remplissez les conditions
d'accès pourquoi ne pas y aller alors
précisons que l'union nationale des
combattants le nc existe en france
depuis 1918 et la fin de la première
guerre mondiale
rien que dans les yvelines on compte
plus de 70 sections vous êtes combien de
membres au sein de cette nouvelle
section à maurepas une quarantaine une
quarantaine d'anciens membres qui était
qu'on fait qu'elle tel type de conflit à
différents les plus il n'ya plus
personne de la guerre 14-18 bien sûr il
ya encore des légendes de 39-45 beaucoup
en afrique du nord et des opex qu'on
appelait des opex et dire des militaires
des opérations extérieures vous même je
crois vous êtes intervenu
en algérie c'est ça oui quel est l'âge
du membre le plus ancien de chez vous
disiez encore des membres de la seconde
guerre mondiale ça doit être 90 100 90
ans
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
l'objectif d'une telle section pour vous
c'est quoi c'est retrouver peut-être
d'anciens camarades ou au moins des gens
qui ont vécu à peu près les mêmes
expériences que vous il ya forcément le
regroupement d'anciens et puis il ya
aussi le souci de maintenir la mémoire
le devoir de mémoire c'est à dire en
participant à toutes les commémorations
les cérémonies de commémorations ne pas
oublier que des français sont morts pour
protéger notre pays et notre nation
également intervenant auprès des jeunes
pour que là aussi il garde la mémoire de
ce qui s'est passé de ce que les anciens
ont fait justement vous parlez des
commémorations il y en aura une
le 8 mai pour pour la victoire contre
les alliés en 45
vous intervenez auprès des plus jeunes
vous le disiez qu'est-ce que où vous
souhaitez intervenir auprès des plus
jeunes peut-être qu est ce que vous
souhaitez mettre en place intervention
en classe échanges
alors pour l'instant il ya une
intervention en classe qui a été fait
par la démonstration d'un de nos anciens
du département pas par quelqu'un de non
pas et les jeunes mille classes de
l'école de la malle menottes ont préparé
un poème
on a pris un champ et ils seront
présents le 8 mai le 8 mai pêchons à mon
père et citron ce poème à l'occasion
quel est votre rapport avec les enfants
aujourd'hui les enfants de 2017 ceux qui
n'ont connu que la paix est heureusement
vous les sentez attentif il est bien
sous le thème serre n'est pas ce que
vous leur dites j'étais dans la classe
n'aurait lieu l'entretien et on les a
sentis attentif quelques questions sont
sortis mais ils ont ils sont été fort
sage pour les trois quarts d'heures
d'intervention
qu'est ce que vous dites concrètement
aux enfants est ce que vous leur parlez
on va dire de peut-être pas de l'horreur
de la guerre concrètement vous leur
parlez quoi c'est plutôt un message en
europe et de ne pas compter historique
et puis
la personne qui est venu à parler
surtout de son vécu mais n'ont
absolument pas d'action de combat autre
chose comme ça à quoi simplement
rappeler ce qui s'est passé est un petit
peu d'événements des gouvernements et
aux autres pourquoi mais pas en fond
l'idée de dire plus plus plus jamais ça
bien sûr si je vous attends mais c'est
ça
quel regard ce sera ma dernière question
sur cette première partie d'entretien
quel regard vous portez aujourd'hui sur
sans parler de politique évidemment mais
sur les conflits actuels que ce soit au
moyen-orient en afrique ou même aux
portes de l'europe sur l'ukraine où on a
aussi des menaces récemment alors on
parle d' internationale entre les états
unis et la corée du nord sans évoquer
une nouvelle fois la politique mais est
ce que vous êtes optimiste vous pour les
générations futures
est-ce que selon vous elles vont vivre
dans la paix où elles vont connaître
comme vous des des périodes de guerre
mais je pense que l'essentiel serait de
maintenir cette notion de paix et des
très très attentif à ce qui peut se
passer en dehors de nos frontières mais
sans oublier que nous avons besoin d'une
armée et de la maintenir en forme
très bien merci philippe paul hubert
rester avec nous on passe tout de suite
à l'actualité de la semaine
on reste un mort par pour débuter ce
tour de l'actualité départementale où
les élèves de l'école défricher du
collège pergaud participer à un parcours
citoyens et institutions initiée par
leurs professeurs face à eux des
pompiers des policiers ou encore des
gendarmes
reportage de mélanie poquet les doyens
relevé et la vraie après cet atelier le
massage cardiaque n'aura plus de secret
pour eux c'est mort passe bien
participent à la journée citoyenneté
organisée par leurs professeurs
n'achetez pas pour le pour les massages
cardiaques n'avaient pas besoin peu
fallait faire plein de 30 pouces et des
airs comme ça j'avais pas j'ai appris
plein de choses bas ya plusieurs choses
que j'avais déjà fait mais après après
le mais le truc vous réanimer une
personne j'avais jamais fait protection
civile policiers ou encore sécurité
routière étaient mobilisés des ateliers
étaient proposés pour parfois défaire
les idées reçues pendant un atelier de
parcours vélo donc on apprend aux élèves
principalement à s'arrêter au stop
comprendre qu'on s'arrête trois secondes
un stock le ciel et le passage vous avez
vu qu'à un sens giratoire à différence
entre un giratoire et un rond-point bons
jeunes bonnes connaissances ensemble et
puis il ya l'effet mimétisme avec l'épée
avec les parents 1 les parents dans la
voiture les enfants sont des éponges et
il récupère bien sûr tout ce que les
parents font bien ou mal
cent trente élèves ont été sensibilisés
le temps de cette journée pour que la
théorie apprise à l'école passe à la
pratique des éditeurs lorsqu'ils voient
obligés à faire pour
en sécurité à responsabilité philippe
hubert on est exactement dans ce dont on
parlait il ya quelques instants
l'initiation des plus jeunes sur le
danger sur la sécurité via internet sur
la route
est ce que vous pensez vous aujourd'hui
que les jeunes c'est un autre regard sur
notre société les jeunes sont plus
vulnérables aujourd'hui face aux
multiples dangers de la société qu'avant
alors on pourrait croire qu on est plus
en sécurité aujourd'hui mais que ce
n'est pas forcément le cas
ou alors vous pensez que au contraire
c'est juste son poids plume érable mais
je pense qu'il faut quand même les
initiés d instruire en plus ils sont
réceptifs beaucoup plus jeunes que nous
sur des informations sur des
manipulations et je crois qu'il faut les
entretenir et les prévenir très bien
merci philippe libère on rappelle qu'il
y à une commémoration une cérémonie à
maurepas c8 le mime et à quelle excuse
et moi 10h30 au cimetière 10h30 au
cimetière et plus tard 11h30 le croit
merci philippe est lui bien je rappelle
que vous êtes secrétaire de la section
des anciens combattants ne ment pas
nouvelle section
merci à vous le devoir de mémoire encore
et toujours dans l'actualité puisqu'il a
débuté jeudi 4 mai à saint quentin en
yvelines une semaine spéciale organisée
par le collectif pour la semaine de la
mémoire de l'esclavagé jusqu'au 10 mai
plusieurs opérations sont organisées sur
le territoire de l'agglomération avec
des conférences des débats ou encore du
sport
mercredi dernier nous recevions l'une
des membres du collectif pour évoquer le
sujet extraits c'est un sujet qui n'est
pas attractif
on ne va pas se vanter d'avoir des
ancêtres esclaves
or il est important à la fois que cette
cette partie de l'histoire soit partagé
non pas sous l'aspect de la
revendication de la réparation parce
qu'on ne saurait pas véritablement
comment travailler cette réparation mais
surtout d'une appropriation comme une
donnée des figures mythiques à ses
descendants
d'esclaves et permettre aux autres on va
dire descendants de colo de se rendre
compte qu'il y avait aussi des figures
mythiques dans le peuple noir
elle encourt le prisme s'est transformé
en laboratoire d'expériences robotique
jeudi dans la salle culturelle se tenait
le deuxième challenge codage et
robotique aussi appelé sky robe une
vingtaine d'établissements de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et y
participer et plus de 600 élèves au
total
reportage il a des allures de vaisseau
spatial et fait la fierté de ses
créateurs signaux étaient entièrement
programmée par ses élèves de ce2 de
l'école le berceau avec les hardy au
programme
le robot et après on appuie sur le
bouton du milieu et
d'après le programme commence un langage
qui n'a presque plus de secrets pour eux
une trentaine de classes de saint
quentin en yvelines a participé au 2e
challenge sky robe
depuis septembre ils ont travaillé avec
leurs professeurs pour arriver à ce
résultat s'apprête à prendre en main un
robot à connaître le vocabulaire
associer le robot et puis aussi le
vocabulaire utilisé par le robot pour
avancer et obéir sur l'allemande aux
ordres qui vont leur donner
donc ça apprend dans toute chose en
termes pédagogiques mais ça a presque eu
l'esprit d'équipé parce qu'ils sont pas
tout seuls à le faire c'est bien
mécanique
c'est ce qu'ils feraient fonctionner à
leurs haut-parleurs ou malheureusement
force est une place sur le robot c'est
leur mouvement après délibération du
jury dark team york repart avec le prix
coup de coeur mais chaque équipe a été
récompensé pour son investissement
cette année plus de 600 élèves sont
devenus apprentis ingénieurs
la poste lance une nouvelle campagne de
recrutement l'entreprise qui compte plus
de 2000 facteurs sur le département
souhaite embaucher une centaine de cdi
sur une base de 35 heures pour des
candidats avec ou sans diplôme c'est
deux fois plus que l'an passé objectif
accompagner la transformation des
différents secteurs de l'entreprise
les détails avec ce sujet d'haussmann
vendeurs d miquel et demi d'euros et
patrick jacques de dixmude la poste
recrute dans les yvelines la direction
vient d'annoncer l'embauché de 145
facteurs d'ici fin 2010 est le double de
l'année dernière cette décision fait
suite à un accord national signé fin
février
ce document prévoit 3000 postiers
supplémentaires sur le territoire
français nous notre objectif est
effectivement de recruter de recruter
des personnels qui eux vont nous
permettre de renforcer notre notre force
de travail donc ça ça reste important
mais c'est pas pour aller plus vite
c'est au contraire pour avoir des
personnes qui soient plus polyvalente
plus qualifiés mais qu'ils puissent
aussi s'adapter à nos métiers depuis le
début de l'année 45 candidats ont déjà
été recrutées en cdd sur le département
les facteurs sont payées sur la base du
smic pour entendre de travail de 35
heures
leurs journées commencent tous les jeux
entre 7h et 8h c'est plutôt dans des
établissements une partie de tri de
préparation du courrier dans le sens de
la tournée avec différents produits tels
que le courrier ou le colis et puis
aller à distribuer tous les produits
autre objectif de ces recrutements
répondre à la livraison 2.0 mise en
place par la poste les nouveaux facteurs
seront formés pendant quinze jours à
leur arrivée pour maîtriser les nouveaux
outils digitaux
au début je croyais que c'était
difficile j'ai eu du mal mais je me suis
je me suis fait je pense que tout le
monde peut s'y faire
moi j'suis pas tout jeune donc je pense
que les pilules alli peuvent s'ils
ferment sur le mois d'avril la poste
recherche principalement des postiers
sur saint quentin en yvelines versailles
rambouillet et croissy-sur-seine aucun
diplôme spécifique n'est demandé il faut
simplement être titulaire d'un permis b
voiture on va s attrape au un forum jobs
d'été de l'apprentissage était organisée
mercredi au gymnase jean guimier une
première dans la commune mise en place
depuis deux mois par la mairie
l'événement a attiré plus d'une
quarantaine d'entreprises et samson
jeunes curieux armés de leur cv et de
leur lettre de motivation michael et
demi d'euros shaima benedit 18 ans n'a
pas hésité à pousser les portes du
gymnase guimier pour participer au
premier grand forum job d'été de
l'apprentissage de trappes sous cette
formule
l'objectif de cette lycéenne en
terminale es trouver un emploi pour la
période estivale niveau dans mon lycée
on nous a
on nous a distribué en fait des petites
feuilles du coup je suis parti me
renseigner à la cyberbase et voilà on
m'a dit hommage il conserve c'est je
trouve vraiment le concept assez
intéressant de ramener différentes
entreprises ça que je me suis déplacé
shy'm avait la possibilité de rencontrer
une quarantaine d'entreprises des
professionnels qui ont travaillé pour
non plus de deux mois avec la mairie
pour participer à cet événement en fait
le but pour nous ça va être de trouver
notamment des stagiaires des alternants
cdd cdi qui pourrait correspondre donc à
nos offres les compétences ne m'importe
m'importe peu ce que je cherchais des
personnalités après plus d'une heure de
recherches et une quinzaine de cv
distribué l'étudiante de 18 ans dresse
un premier bilan
c'est un salon qui est assez intéressant
parce que voilà j'ai fait plusieurs
plusieurs stands sont assez différents
on nous parle de l'entreprise de ce
qu'ils font particulièrement de ce
qu'ils proposent
l'événement a attiré plus de 500 jeunes
vu le succès rencontré cette année le
rendez vous devrait être renouvelée
l'année prochaine
vous l'avez peut-être remarqué si vous
avez pour habitude de passer près du
quartier de la boissière le secteur du
stade des peupliers à plaisir est
actuellement en travaux des bassins de
rétention d'eau sont en construction ils
doivent permettre d'éviter de nouvelles
inondations de la commune après les
problèmes survenus l'an passé les
terrains avaient alors été ravagés
miquel et demi d'euros et patrick
jacques de dixmude les pieds dans l'eau
à plaisir ce sera bientôt de l'histoire
ancienne après avoir subi deux
inondations février et juin 2016 dans le
quartier de la boissière
la ville est en train de recréer des
bassins de rétention d'eau au niveau des
terrains des peupliers six semaines de
travaux pour un coût de 160 19000 euros
il y avait des bassins mais en valent
ils vont être déplacés a grandi et on va
aussi buzet de façon beaucoup plus large
l'écoulement des eaux
vous savez quand l'eau circule dans un
usage trop étroits après quand il sort
il ne peut pas se répandre et l'eau a
besoin de place un besoin d'un lit
d'installation quand elle déborde et à
partir de ce moment là il était question
il fallait absolument revoir tous les
coups fruste et de l'écoulement il n'y
avait pas que les terrains des peupliers
qui était dans une problématique
il y avait également le quartier
les quelques maisons qui étaient en bas
la petite zone pavillonnaire une fois
les bassins terminé la ville remettra à
flot les terrains synthétiques submergé
pendant les inondations des équipements
utilisés principalement par les
scolaires et les associations sportives
de la commune
ça ça va demandera tout l'été pour
pouvoir effectivement les mettre en
route à partir du mois de septembre
c'est plus d'un million de largement
quand vous l'aménager complètement
autour et bien sûr nous on y avait
ajouté en plus des vestiaires donc ça
coûte vraiment cher mais si aujourd'hui
ce que de vendre les sportifs donc a pas
de raison qu'on ne fasse pas un
accompagnement à ce niveau là mais comme
je le disais nous sommes aidés par
rapport aux assurances en parallèle des
travaux sur les terrains la municipalité
va en profiter pour créer à quelques
mètres un parking supplémentaire de 72
places pour fluidifier le stationnement
sur le secteur rendez vous début
septembre pour voir toutes ces
transformations
c'est un nom qui ne vous dit sûrement
pas grand chose le football club de
phoenix et une nouvelle équipe créée il
ya quelques semaines uniquement aux
composés de réfugiés le fcp sont rien à
chaque samedi matin sur un terrain à
versailles l'initiative est portée par
des bénévoles avec l'idée de créer du
lien entre les réfugiés les footballeurs
locaux
stéphane servant et nicolas d'andré
soudanais somaliens ou afghans hébergés
à versailles ou dans les environs se
retrouve désormais chaque semaine pour
une séance d'entraînement de football
ils sont une vingtaine à s'adonner à ce
sport universel à l'initiative d'une
association de bénévoles voisins
solidaires 78 ce collectif de bénévoles
accompagnent déjà les réfugiés il
participe avec la croix-rouge à des
distributions de nourriture à des
sorties et un suivi administratif
ils ont alors senti une forte demande de
faire du sport ensemble du football en
particulier
c'est simplement pour un pouvoir
proposer une activité
à nos amis réfugiés parce que ils sont
ils n'ont pas la possibilité de
travailler
donc il faut les divertir leur trouver
des occupations et on pensait que le
foot était une des occupations possible
l'occasion de créer des liens entre les
joueurs de différentes communautés et
des habitants curieux et souvent
bienveillant des joueurs amateurs très
heureux de jouer ensemble
je suis très heureux de jouer ici avec
les autres réfugiés de différents pays
et une gifle en crise prochaine étape
des matchs avec des équipes de foot
local une rencontre est déjà prévu en
mai et d'autres se préparent en région
parisienne grâce à la page facebook du
football club phénix un moyen de
développer de nouveaux contacts de
trouver des bénévoles et de lancer une
cagnotte pour acheter des équipements
pour les joueurs et justement si vous
souhaitez soutenir cette initiative vous
pouvez vous rendre sur la page facebook
du phénix football-club de versailles on
referme ce journal avec un coup d'oeil
sur l'événement sportif du week end la
première édition du jumping
international
à versailles les meilleurs cavaliers du
monde sont réunis jusqu'à dimanche dont
le champion olympique français
originaires du chéné et kevin staut
au total ce sont 130 cavaliers et 200
chevaux qui évolue tout le week-end dans
la cour de la grande écurie du roi à
versailles notre journaliste michael et
demi d'euros à rencontrer cette semaine
le directeur sportif de l'épreuve pour
évoquer le succès populaire de cette
première écoute et nous en tant
qu'organisateur en a mis moins d'un an à
construire ce projet donc être rapide
n'ont pas trop rapide parce qu'il
fallait une fois qu'on a dit go il
fallait il fallait le produire mais
c'était vraiment cette très court
puisque on a aussi d'autres occupations
et sincèrement quand on organise un
événement comme ça le fait déjà d'avoir
vendu l'ensemble des places sur trois
jours avant que ça commence montrent
effectivement l'engouement et je crois
que l'engouement il ya un mélange de
curiosité
peut-être de dire qu'est ce qu'ils vont
nous montrer ici à versailles dans les
écuries du roi aussi de d'amener
dans cette ville dans ce lieu dédié au
cheval le lieu nous sommes las de
ramener ce type de compétition et je
crois que l'ensemble de tous ces
paramètres
et aussi je pense pouvoir dire que les
les aficionados sont connaissent le
concours que nous organisons déjà à
chantilly et savent quel type de
concours de spectacle on peut produire
et envie de voir ce qu'on est capable de
faire
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo merci
de nous avoir suivi tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver en replay sur tv fil 78
points comme ou l'application tv fil 78
bon week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]